all right welcome to another edition of
the chest up chest openings explained
I'll be your host Jonathan trance and
this is the class where we get your
input from YouTube and the openings that
you submit we app we bring them up and
we play one thing things that could be
your favorite opening so today I decided
I'd do something very interesting
because I wasn't very overwhelmed with
the the responses that I got from my
last video we need more people saying
this is a great chance you know you're
going to get your favorite openings on
YouTube explained and it's a pretty
well-known fact that the Chess Club in
Scholastic Center is the most
technologically advanced chess club in
the entire world so it's my great
pleasure to present to you the wrong
4000 that's right we have a random
opening generator
so the wrong 4000 is very high class and
will do an excellent job weeding out all
the bad openings and selecting just the
perfect one for tonight's class so all
right without further ado I'll go ahead
I'll check what's going on in the box
I'll give it a good shape
all right let's see what the first one
is let's see very exciting and the
French defense which we've already done
so all right I guess it's not as high
class as I thought but it was mentioned
that maybe somebody mentioned they want
to see a whole series on the French so
if you are interested in that we might
be doing that soon if people really want
to see it but uh but not tonight we're
doing something something new hopefully
something exciting let's see let's see
yeah
all right the the exchange love not
tonight not tonight
we did something positional last week
but is alright here we go here we go
we're not messing around anymore alright
it's better be a good one excellent
there we go so tonight our opening is
the Sicilian dragon and this was sent in
from one of my earlier videos if I
remember right and I'm going to mess up
this name so I apologize in advance but
the Sicilian dragon was requested from
Thor in de nimda jiff sorry I didn't
know chance to pronounce in the name but
alright that's what we're doing tonight
Sicilian dragon alright so this is an
excellent one it's a very exciting
opening this is the exact kind of
opening I was hoping to do tonight so
let's let's have a look it's also one of
my my favorite openings so I'm in luck
because I all know what I'm talking
about tonight all right so this is
Cillian one of the best ways for black
to try to fight for a win early on
already there's an imbalance with the
move c5 he's fighting for control over
the d4 square so normally white will try
to play d4 anyway but he's going to
bring his knight out first
now he's prepared to play d4 and if
there's a capture he's prepared to take
with this Knight and there's a lot of
different moves that black can play in
this position welcome Scott and okay
we're going to look at a d6 line the
point of this move is to be able to
bring your Night Out to f6 without
having to worry about the e5 push you
know harassing your knight
kicking you around so alright d-4s
promised and now we enter what is known
as the open Sicilian so you can take
with a queen here too it's it's possible
we'll just just briefly show normally
this is this is the idea it's not as
common and then you know white will
either place 493 but that's one possible
continuation but the most popular is to
take with a knight it's just the most
logical and now the point of d6 was to
be able to bring out this Knight so
that's it you know a very natural move
attacking the pawn so Knight c3
defending the pawn now at the top level
when they reach this position the most
common move is a6 which is the knight
ourf
and so that's kind of the most respected
opening and uh I think it was a Hikaru
Nakamura who said at the highest level
if you're going to play the Sicilian you
have to play the knight or if it's it's
just the most sound and the best way to
play against it but he's been known to
play the dragon in several US
Championships so normally when he's
playing a 2600 or so Nakamura will play
the dragon so some really good people
have played it Carlsen plays it Reggie
Baul plays it I think upon check plays
it a lot so you do you do see it a bit
the dragon so we're entering an ultra
sharp and a super exciting opening now
there's a classical way to play we're
going to look at this move because I've
decided we're going to look at the
Yugoslavia TAC okay you can play just
classically and then you can just you
know develop and castle that's fine if
four is the leavened fish attack that's
also interesting it's not supposed to be
very good for white but it is very
dangerous so if you are a dragon player
you should have a look at it but tonight
we're going to go for the Yugoslavia
attack a really aggressive system where
white is going to castle on the Queen
side and he's going to go right for a
checkmating attack so after a few more
normal moves okay the bishop goes here
blacks getting ready to castle and it's
worth noting in this position that
sometimes with a bishop on e3 Knight to
g4 is a big threat
and this has been on our YouTube channel
before if I'm not mistaken I think it
was a Yasir video but this is a huge
mistake and already black has made a
game-ending blunder so I'll let the
audience we got a good audience tonight
so we'll see if the audience can find
the right move here for white we got a
lot of people here tonight so so we can
do it
very interesting have you got it
excellent Bishop to b5 check now okay so
you've got to block the check obviously
not with the Queen the most natural
would be to block with the bishop but
now what will white play what's the
tactic your air in this show takes d7
okay if you play here I can protect my
knight so this is kind of the point
we're trying to win this night you see
how we have a queen attacking the knight
so that's what we're trying to do so if
you just trade right away right then he
gets to protect his knight right
excellent we just take the knight
awesome it's because of the pin we just
want a piece it's no different if they
they play here okay this guy's still
hanging and this is not much better
either because I'm going to take this
and you're in a lot of trouble still so
okay so that would be a huge mistake so
that's one that we should know so the
most common move is to get the bishop
out now the King has the f8 squared that
he can run to so this check isn't going
to be as effective anymore so at this
point white will normally play f3 and
this is where we can officially call
this a yugoslavia tack White's plan is
to get his Queen out and castle on the
Queen side then he's going to use his
pawns as kind of a battering ram to
attack the king and he's going to charge
his pawns and he's going to go attack
attack and he's going to hope for for
success if he lines his Queen and Bishop
up of course he can go and try to trade
for the dragon Bishop so we'll see some
of that today okay the most natural move
is just the castle that's the main move
Knight to d2 getting ready to castle as
well and now the move Knight to c6
protects the e5 square so now black is
ready to push with d5 and there's
actually a big choice here for white he
can choose between three different moves
each with a lot of theory behind them
so okay the most common and the one I've
chosen to look at just now we're going
to look at our Bishop to c4 because it's
the sharpest and it leads to some of the
most exciting games the point of this
move is just to prevent black can play
in d5 also popular is a castling and g4
which is a very positional way to play
we'll briefly look at castling so we can
kind of try to understand the mainline
when you play this d5 was blacks point
so okay so normally white will take this
and black will take back and now white
has the chance to inflict a structural
structural weakness on the queenside
so he takes the knight hopefully he's
thinking maybe I have something on the
dark squares over here on the Queen side
you know it is kind of risky as well
obviously the B file is now open so it
might be really useful there but uh okay
he has some stuff to work with for
example after the main move which is
trying to to exchange this very
dangerous bishop on g7 black and do a
few things well you'll to take the
bishop that's that's a very logical
approach actually but five is the
mainline
assuming I'm remembering anything right
but I think I am alright then Bishop to
c5 and the most common move might
surprise you because it's not rook e8 so
the most common move is actually Bishop
to e6 all right so if you move your rook
now we'll see white entering some of
those dark squares
you know Knight to e4 looking in here
he's going to jump in he's going to
cause some damage and okay it's like for
example I'll just show this variation
it's not necessarily the best black
should probably develop this bishop but
I'll show this just because there's a
neat tactic here that I that I know of
after Knight to d6 black can you know
pin this Knight so if you take my rook
I'm going to take your Bishop but what
actually has a really cool move that you
might not expect if you haven't seen
this before but it's Bishop to b5 a
really cool move the point is if you
take I take with check and then I get
your rook and if you know if you take
here then also I'm taking this guy so
it's a nice neat little tactic and
there's going to be a lot of tactics in
this kind of opening so that's what kind
of stuff we're going to hope to see
today but we're going to focus on Bishop
to c4 okay it's just a very logical move
now you're not going to play d5 and
we're beginning to see the plans once
both sides have castled and developed
all their pieces we're going to start
looking at you know what the plans are
for white what the plans are for black
so you have a good chance of finding
them in your own games White's plan is
going to be kind of straightforward he's
going for an attack black is going to
try to maybe make use of this C file so
he has some some pressure and we'll look
very often there's a big theme will be
the standard tactic in the in most
Sicilians rook takes c3 when it doubles
the the pawns
so occasionally the sacrifice is going
to be on the cards here
alright so normally we'll castle alright
so blacks just going to bring his rook
out and there's some tricks with the
discoveries here so white will Park down
this Bishop on b3 and we'll see okay
blacks typical plan is 95 to c4 to force
white to give up the light squared
bishop so that's his big strategy and
he's going to hope for a lot a lot of
play over there on the Queen on the
Queen side so he can checkmate the white
king so okay we'll just jump into the
database now we'll just find a game from
this position I think that'll be the
good way to just continue so we can see
it in an actual game and let's let black
win the first game so we'll look at the
highest
black players to play it okay so this is
the game between karyakin and raja baath
and we'll go ahead and flip the board I
know I flip the board okay and we'll
check it out from the very beginning
again so again we can see this one more
time alright so yeah I picked this game
because I Reggie Bob was right on the
top he's played this quite a lot of
times and his games are usually really
exciting so we'll see how how black wins
this game let's see so we have the
Sicilian and then what move makes it the
dragon
yes awesome g6 we got the dragon all
right so we got Yugoslavia Tech whites
getting ready and I will see the Bishop
c4 line okay and all right so castles
rook c8 and now we'll see what White's
going to do the most common move here is
h4 all right sorry actually you drop
back first and then after Knight to e5
h4 is the most common move but King b1
was played so yeah the main remove is h4
and then h5 this is very typical often
you meet h4 with h5 in this line and it
might seem strange because you know
you're you know moving pawns in front of
your King which is not something you
want to do unless it's going to slow
down White's attack and here it usually
does and there's a typical sacrifice in
this line and this is known as the
Soltis variation it's with this
sacrifice you're giving up a pawn and
you'll even give up another so this is
just a very typical way to really open
it up White's going as fast as he can
he's trying to crush black and okay this
sort of thing will happen and white will
get tremendous pressure for the pawns
that he sacrificed so the game will
probably be pretty similar
after King to be one this is the modern
way to play and that's why it's called
the modern variation so normally now
black plays rook to e8 okay so white
made kind of a waiting move normally
black makes a waiting move here rook to
e8 is that the most common way that way
if white ever wants to trade these
bishops he can always go back without
losing his rook on f8 so and uh okay
this this strikes me is a little bit
strange because a6 is usually too slow
in these lines but something tells me he
did his homework and he knew what he was
doing so alright now I was expecting a
six h4 so will he respond with h5 all
right now I'm expecting g4 he's going to
just rip it open and he did so after we
take you don't want to take bad
that would be terrible because you know
all of these captures look really good
you got a lot of things that can take
there and then you know this if you take
this way you know you're going to be
able to block the H file which is key to
black strategy he's trying to keep
things as closed as you can so I'm
expecting h5 all right and now you want
to take with the night taking with the
pawn is very risky because sometimes
this bishops going to come in here and
you're threatening to bring your Queen
in and all right and then there's some
pins here notice how good this guy is so
you can get into a lot of trouble you're
trying to keep things as closed as
possible in Knight to h5 which I guess I
better check that as actually played
it's a very common move this guy is
actually quite good here even though
he's on the rim he's kind of blocking
the h-file
so white will sometimes think about this
sacrifice it's it's premature but he's
thinking about sometimes opening up the
G file by taking this Knight probably
when he has some other pieces in here
you know the Queen can come over to some
squares and you can start getting you
can see how a big attack is coming so
let's see so black better at some point
get something going for himself so okay
so all the standard moves that we might
expect so this is all very typical now
I'm expecting Knight to c4 but it wasn't
played so one common idea is just to
play Knight to c4 and white really
doesn't want to part with his dark
squared Bishop because his counterpart
is one of black strongest pieces this
excellent diagonal here can cause a lot
of problems for white at some point you
know you might think about some
sacrifices and you're thinking about
some checkmates that Bishop is really
good when a black is attacking there on
the king and the Queen side so what
would be compelled to trade and then the
rook would take this is sort of a
typical way but uh okay so he waited on
that and he played Queen a5 now it's
interesting because there's a trick here
that we should know when we play the
dragon and I like to call it the dragon
trap because it's something that happens
in the dragon all the time whenever the
Queen goes to a5 and that is white can
sometimes play the move Knight to d5
and want to see why this doesn't work
here the point is the queen is attacked
you uncovered an attack and if you trade
Queens before you take the Queen back
you'll throw this check in now this King
is going to have to move and we're going
to take the Queen back and we're you
know so you want a pond and sometimes as
is the case here white will know this
and you'll still go in for it so just
because you're losing that pond doesn't
mean you don't want to stop thinking but
now we'll have to figure out why
probably there's some tricks with this
guy I don't know let's see they don't
see any good tricks maybe even like a
simple move is probably a good move
Knight to c6 yeah the problem is now
this guy that was kind of trapped a
little bit in my territory now I've
given them an escape route out I can
take take the rook with the knight is
threatening a rook and I take c8 let's
see right so I get one move let's see
okay it is interesting because I wonder
why he didn't didn't go in for this so I
guess I'll move this guy huh I don't
really want to leave the C file though
but okay umm yeah so it's interesting
and it's just an idea worth with known
in the back of your mind so yeah after
one Queen eighty-five you always got to
be ready for a Knight to d5 so okay
Bishop to h6 all right very logical he's
just going to trade off the dark squared
Bishop s' then he's going to hope to
open up some stuff here a little bit
more open the H file open the G file get
is rooks and major pieces in the you
know after some exchange maybe the Queen
will will be able to move over and often
Black has to consider now do you want to
take the bishop and let the Queen in
or do you even want to move the bishop
and drop an exchange which was played so
he's willing to part with an exchange
already to get control over the dark
squares which is a very interesting
strategy if he would have played the
waiting move rook to e8 in before
instead of the move a six then ok this
possibility wouldn't exist here so let's
see so you can take it or you can take
on g4 first ok so that was played just
opening the the G file bikes going to
take it back and now will he take the
rook we can give up the dark square
control and it's something you don't
want to just do oh it's obvious ok
that's worth five my piece is worth
three but this is a very nice piece so
let's see if he if he was willing to to
exchange and he was so now I picked up
some material what's going to be most
important in these lines is going to be
peace play it's a lot more important
than that than anything else like in
material or you know some other factors
sometimes even pawn structure what's
really important is that you have really
nice pieces and so that's what black is
arguing here so he's arguing this Bishop
is really nice black will take with the
King the rook is really nice on c8 so we
shouldn't take back with the rook so he
took with the King all right and now
let's see what what White's going to do
here yeah also okay so see sometimes
there's tricks here you do give up
another exchange all right what else see
he did it okay so very interesting he's
given up two exchanges here and he's
going into an endgame because White's
going to take with the Queen if you're
going to ruin your pawn structure it
doesn't really make sense to keep the
Queen's on the board so he took with a
queen and black took back and okay so
now he's down to exchanges but he has
these two pawns so two pawns for two
exchanges so and this is very typical of
the dragon like I knew we were going to
get something exciting because that's a
really strange imbalance that you don't
see every day
and all right so these pieces they look
pretty good let's see how black puts
them to good use here
so II six now this guy isn't doing very
much this is you know this Bishop is a
little bit locked out and that's as much
as it is about black getting his pieces
to active squares it's also about
shutting out the white pieces so okay a
nice little move and now a little
tactical move the point is if you take
then a
we're exchanging bishops and white
saying well my bishop isn't doing a
whole lot there so I'll trade it for
your Bishop on g4 because he doesn't
want to end up with that that bad piece
so what you probably want to take it
because then your night ends up in a
great square so he took it and they
exchanged bishops okay so now black
still has to think about how he's going
to untangle here
he's probably got to get these pieces to
some better squares here so so Bishop to
e5 and now rope to g2 okay he's
protecting the d2 square maybe and it'll
be interesting to see okay that's what I
was thinking I didn't want to say it but
that's what I was thinking
the point is to stop white from playing
the move a4 as much as it is you know
creating a nice home for your knight
because now if you play a four at any
moment we'll be able to take it and have
a passed pawn so okay so now there's a
little threat all right he's threatening
a little cheap threat sure you saw it
all right and it's nice to have the King
over here now if this Knight moves this
rook isn't infiltrating because your
Kings on a good square so and at some
point this Knight will probably end up
going to f6 getting some pressure on
this pawn here all right and a4 was
played anyway so now black can take it
and he took it all right King came up
how is house black going to make
progress Knight f6 mind f6 so he
attacked upon he's come into a more
active square he was kind of done on the
side we're no longer tariff
you know the rooks infiltrating on the
h-file that's a long way off and we'll
be able to defend okay so the pond was
protected all right very interesting yes
so he's he's saying if you take my deep
on I'm gonna have three pass ponds and
that's what happened so all right now
for your your two exchanges you're up
some ponds and they're looking really
good now so blacks strategy is just
going to be a sort of a technical idea
for he's going to push all of his ponds
and so we'll see what happens notice
that this King is really boxed out he's
not like entering the game his only job
is to babysit these pawns so that they
don't advance and if you just compare
the quality of the pieces Lex pieces are
just way better than then the white
rooks even though you know
then the knight and the bishop that he
has for the exchange really nice all
right so he can start you should
thinking about giving up an exchange
okay this is an interesting idea so I'll
take it we're not going to throw the
check in I'm just going to take it do
you have like a follow-up for white or
you're just hoping to reduce the the
pieces where we've you're going to move
the rook where are you going to go so g1
um okay I'll probably take this with
check okay and this
I don't yeah it doesn't feel like white
really obtained too much from from this
I mean you know you have your rooks
that's your your one big Trump if you're
white you have those the extra heavy
pieces so he'll probably try to keep
them as long as you can and if you trade
too many pieces it's going to be really
easy to push my King side pawns so he
probably wants to keep as many pieces on
the board as possible at the moment so
rook h3 was played okay he protected his
pawn but what's this
do I not have a fork here I just have to
consider if I want to take your night
first so it looks like he is giving up
an exchange so he just he did it in a
different way
all right so he took the night first and
now I expect a nice Fork
all right so black is winning material
here so after he picks which rook he
wants to save all right so now it's it's
a real person night but the most
important factor is obviously these
ponds so it's time for them to start
going the king has like no chance of
ever getting back here that's just he's
kind of far locked out of the game and
the rook isn't going to be able to
contain three pawns so let's see what
happens
g5 here it goes all right the pawn is
attacked I think he'll protect it and
okay so he attacks the night it's worth
trying to calculate if you can just push
and ignore but you can probably just
move the knight out of danger is it
working
okay so he moved his knight well it just
keeps attacking it and okay now he's in
a good position he's always going to be
able to apply can be able to protect his
knight he's gonna be able to keep
pushing these guys so white also says
okay I've got a pastor he's got to get
some counter place somehow so the black
King though is just going to be in time
the black King can come over here and
you know guard against these these pawns
so okay so black goes so it's a race but
the black King is going to be able to
stop White's past pawn and it's not
obvious how wide is going to you know
stop black so he can trade here so he
probably should get rid of that guy okay
so this is also trading pawns all right
so black got rid of the passer and now
will he be able to get one of these guys
to become a queen all right so when you
when you have passed pawns and you can
push them safely you should push them
Knights attacked probably you can push
your pawn or bring your king in all
right he brings the King in you're
probably not threatening to take the
knight so and this is nice to like you
so you take the night with check but
it's all about King activity now a king
and two pawns is too much for a rook and
this guy is way too far away so all
right when you can push your pawns you
should alright and he says I'll remind
you I also have this guy all right now a
two was a nice move so a five is good
all right
a two and that was the game so an
excellent technique a man that was that
was a good game so most games are the
dragon you can almost guarantee that
they're going to be fun and exciting
like this black gave up two exchanges so
a crazy imbalance and a lot of fun and
then he showed some really good
technique those past pawns on the Queen
side were just too much for a white to
handle okay we'll find one more game
we'll go back we'll go back to our our
initial position here and we'll pick one
more and we'll pick a game from white
let's see let's see white win a game
here so this is Magnus Carlsen versus
Teemo raja baath this was played in 2008
so it's interesting Carlsen am raja
baath they both play this a lot so I
think it'll be entertaining to see these
two play this out because they're both
very proficient at this opening so this
is it this is two of the the top dragon
experts in the world going at it so
let's see what happens
the Sicilian the open Sicilian we
protect our pawn and we're planning for
the Yugoslavia TAC all right so they
castle all right so Bishop to c4 is what
we're looking at after castling okay
rook to c8 is the the most common move
but here interesting we have a Chinese
dragon this move is a very special move
his point is he's going to play a move
like Nene five attacking the bishop and
a5 and the Knights going to jump into c4
that way if the bishop takes the knight
on c4 he's going to be able to open up
the B file and he's going to get a lot
of pressure on the White King I'm so
very very interesting way to play I
don't it's not supposed to be super
popular at the
top grand master level it's a little
suspicious normally black goes all in
for a big attack on the Kings side and
but okay but it's it's often fails so
we'll see what happens here
I think Bishop b3 is the most common
move okay now I'd expect either 95 or b5
so okay and the point is he's not going
to take this guy the point is he's gonna
play b5 and jump his knight in to c4
okay we saw in the last game you know
King b1 is just a good move and often in
this variation the White King will
actually end up on a 1 so really tucked
away safe because eventually the B file
is going to open up and you don't want
your King on the same file as a rook
because there will be some some tactical
ideas so we'll see if any of that
happens so b5 at some point you know
he's going to play h4 if white you got
to time it right
h4 so will he play h5 really just go in
for it let's see and this is usually a
little bit different I think in this
line the black just gets on with what
he's doing most of the time so we see
that here alright so the Queen and
Bishop are attacked so he's got to trade
the night and this is what we're talking
about so the B file is open and there's
a king on the B file so occasionally
you're gonna have some tricks because
these squares are not really protected
the way you might think they are because
it the pawn is pinned so let's see
King a1 so far I'm doing a good job yeah
so the King gets tucked away on a 1 so
you're not on the B file and actually
maybe I've seen this game alright I
think I actually know this game so
alright so will we see g4 normally g4
isn't as effective in this line yes yeah
so I haven't seen this game before I
remember this move was a very nice move
he Carlson does a really good job in
this game he understands all of his
opponents possible threats occasionally
you know the queen is going to go to
either be six or a five have some
pressure here and okay he's stopping it
before you even have a chance and if I
remember this game and I only vaguely do
he
he really is good he makes a lot of
prophylactic moves and then black ends
up with an attack that doesn't work and
then white just succeeds in a and
crushing black on the kingside so let's
see all right so now again when the
Queen goes to a5 we want to ask do we
have the dragon trap Knight d5 that's
the first move that I want to think
about what it wasn't played so let's go
ahead and look at it
Knight to d5 let's see if we trade and
you take and the King will move
somewhere you'll take back are there
some tricks well I mean immediately I
can just take this and then I'll snatch
this guy up I'm just wondering if this
is even stronger my idea is if you move
here I'm going to play route to b6 which
is often where this rook wants to be in
this variation because you're going to
double up on the B file and all right
looks like you're going to lose some
material because you know what your
Knights are going to fall I have ideas
of taking here I'm just taking this
Knight
so it looks looks pretty miserable so
that's why the dragon trap doesn't work
here so alright Bishop to h6 so should
black take should he retreat and let you
know white take the rook like we saw in
the last game all right
he takes and so the Queen will take back
and it's a kind of a good idea now there
might be some tricks eventually on this
square if the Queen is far away it looks
kind of scary the Queen is right next to
your King but you're not really doing
anything just yet and a so black okay he
might develop his rooks he might double
you know rooks might swing over these
are the kinds of things that happen a
lot in this line so rook to b6 was
played and now okay
probably we can go back if we want we
can just really protect this Knight so
there's never any tricks move like 90
Knight to e2 let's see
but g4 okay on with the attack so blacks
probably thinking can I can you ignore
it does he have to take he
took now will we CH 5 or another move ok
Queen to e3 so he's protecting us night
so there's not any tricks there
eventually
which position ok you want to take back
this way alright it looks rather risky
so I have two different ways that I can
I can capture this guy I'm not even so
concerned with attacking your queen I
think I'll just play here just so that
you know eventually I can just park here
you'll never open up the H file I
probably you know this is probably good
too
makes a lot of sense as well you'll be
jumping back into some good squares here
maybe eventually but the Queen wants to
retreat somewhere so but okay this is
probably good for for black as well yeah
so I suppose I mean white isn't really
concerned with this move opening the G
file a little bit more you know so it
moves you know like h5 might be coming
but it is worth noting to the Queen on
a5 as in with a lot of Sicilian dragons
does a good job protecting the h5 square
so I've seen a lot of games where people
just miss that
I'll make some bad moves you know
they'll think they're they're shattering
open the King and then they'll realize
that there's a queen here so don't let
that happen to you alright so that's
interesting let's see so he doubled so
what will white do haole somehow he's
got to make some threats or he's got to
play some defense ok so he goes for it
anyway he's not afraid of opening
position so black can take with a knight
or you can play g5 which is interesting
this is a common move that you actually
see in the dragon a lot when you play g5
you're just keeping the game shut you
don't want to open the Kings side at all
so all right an interesting move now
white captured so black and take back
either way takes up the knight attacking
the Queen
maybe the knight is also thinking about
hopping back to h6 blockading the pawn
and being very very say
so okay now occasionally we might well
we're not probably without a rook here
we're never really going to have any of
this going on because even if you take
here you'll be able to move your king to
f8 so okay he's just protecting that
night so that you know there's no
tactics and now yeah very interesting
so what is white doing here it's it
looks like black is really solid so
somehow white better play a good move
here Knight to d5 all right take this
yeah I mean you want to sacrifice your
pieces in the dragon but not that bad
okay
so I don't know what what's our
protagonist going to play here
let's see Knight to f3 yo this is a very
good move so what has to do something
he's aiming for a 5 and Knight takes g5
you know getting in at the king alright
very very interesting so it's getting
very exciting let's see what's going on
here okay so now right I'm always
looking if there's ever going to be any
any tricks any captures here that are
going to work just we'll see so he's not
threatening anything just yet
okay so he kicks the night away and
black makes a big threat okay so we can
no longer just go through with this idea
because what does black play here let's
make sure I'm right
alright I didn't come right what was
blacks threat he played rook to b4 for a
reason
we have a very strong player in the
audience now so he will he will surely
find it he's been doing a lot of tactics
lately
we'll only mention his name if he gets
it right all right who's the tactical
Wizard rook to a4 I'm giving up an
exchange my queen is protected so my
queen is protected are you just taking
the knight and you have much better so
let's think for a second all right she's
gonna take it with your queen and you're
threatening a checkmate but I see it
yeah so now I don't I don't see a
follow-up for you like this sacrifice
doesn't work for example because I get
to run away okay but yet you have much
better here you know that or I'm going
to look really foolish on the internet
so hopefully I'm right here
alright they seems pretty
straightforward hopefully you guys found
it at home
Queen takes a to this just this is the
crusher only move is to take back rook
takes King takes rook a for checkmate
notice how useful this pawn is so the
King can't run away checkmate so he made
a threat so let's see did Carlson fall
for it and get checkmated alright let's
get back to our position here he saw it
so he played a three he's not
threatening to take the rook he's
preventing checkmate and all right so
we're always going to be wondering you
know we got to make sure you're
calculating all these these sacrifices I
don't think black has a threat here so
alright Bishop to e6 alright he's
looking looking at his own pond I would
get mad at my students if they played
that game but if red robe off played hit
the hell back alright you're the best so
will we see d5 yes how will he take back
all right is he going to take on g5
alright so this looks extremely risky so
I doubt he took it right mm-hm alright
this just looks way too dangerous I
don't know where you're going but I have
this guy he's looking pretty good
threatening to win a little bit of
material here but yeah like h6 looks
like it's it's going to be pretty good
in this position so it looks extremely
dangerous to take it so he just left it
alone
I moved his Bishop and again it was
attacked by the knight
alright is the bishop gonna do anything
tactical here let's see okay so the
knight jumps back
okay so he's blockading the pond how is
white gonna make more progress though
okay so he's he's thinking about about
this and taking and taking back putting
a little bit of material so now let's
let's get serious about some of these
these sacrifices over here
all right probably nothing works so
alright um okay so Queen to G - looks
pretty crushing okay this move also
doesn't look bad
it's a funny Bishop he just keeps going
back and forth you can't decide but okay
but it's white that needs to prove he's
getting black good here alright
um again you could probably bring the
Queen over but okay this this doesn't
look too bad either let's see alright so
that keeps the night there okay and he
goes into this pin but alright now we
got our our power pieces here on the
open G file so we got something good
coming up it's alright so it's a
discovered attack the knight is hanging
but also we're allowed some checks a
very nice move Knight to g5 merit it was
taken and now the queen is getting some
access she's trying to come in here
taking on g6 looks really risky I assume
like h6 looks like it's a big Russian
move this also looks like it wins and
the game ended here it's hard to stop me
from playing there even something like
this
so I'm distracting you hoping for one
trick that I get to take your queen but
uh okay if you take this you're still
threatening to to bring your Queen in
with checkmate
so man another really exciting game and
I like the way that white played this at
the beginning we'll get back to the
finish here which was here yeah so
that's what happens in the Chinese
dragon it's a very exciting way to play
for black sometimes you just get a lot
of pressure
the queenside and you just checkmate
white immediately and then you look like
a genius it is a bit dubious at the
higher levels Carlson did a really good
job just defending it looked a little
perilous for him at first but he kept
his eye for all the tactical
opportunities and eventually he broke
through Knight f3 was a really good move
just threatening to take on g5 and
opening up the game so a very
well-played game so good job to the box
he worked really hard today you picked a
good one so hopefully if you guys liked
it you'll you'll hit like subscribe send
some feedback and send in your games
maybe we'll pick your favorite next week
thanks guys good job to the box it's a
fantastic box and it only took three
tries to get a good opening